Speaker 1: Today, I'm going to talk about
the hypocrisy of Republicans when it comes
to business freedom that they claim to espouse
and low regulations which they claim to support.
And this is all kind of coming on the heels
of yesterday's Ron DeSantis Disneyworld.
I'll build a prison next to Disney.
Threat and controversy, which is really just
one of dozens and dozens of data points of
Republicans who claim to be about business
freedom and low regulation, immediately abandoning
that principle to the extent that it's even
a principle as soon as it's politically inconvenient.
Now, in order to understand where this hypocrisy
comes from and why it's so glaring today,
you really have to understand the history
of the Republican Party As for decades and
decades and decades, claiming to be the party
of business, freedom of low regulations, of
economic freedom and pro-business and all
of these things they said for decades.
Excessive regulation is a burden on businesses
and it hurts profits and it stifles economic
growth and therefore it prevents hiring.
And the best thing we can do for workers and
for the economy and for investors for everybody,
is to keep regulations low and stay out of
the way of businesses.
Let the market decide which businesses succeed
and which businesses fail.
The truth is so much more pathetic.
It's we support business freedom in theory,
when it suits our interests and doesn't conflict
with personal vendettas, grievances, or other
inconvenient realities.
Now, let's take a look at some examples and
again, understand that there was a period,
even if you disagree with this obsessive focus
on unburdening businesses of regulations,
you might disagree with that.
We can still acknowledge that at a certain
point, conservatives, as they once were, were
actually much more committed to that.
I would still disagree with them in many cases
and say, no, we need regulation.
But there was a point at which when they said
it, they meant it.
That's not the case anymore.
Twitter.
Twitter is a recent example.
That's a glaring one when it comes to Twitter.
Many of these right wingers immediately abandoned
their stated principles of getting rid of
burdensome regulations and separating government
from what private companies do, and said no,
Twitter should be forced to publish my COVID
disinformation.
Twitter should be forced to publish Hunter
Biden nude pics which violate their own terms
of service.
Twitter should be forced to let governments
decide or the government decide what hateful,
idle ideology or hateful speech should be
published.
Rather than saying Let Twitter figure out
what it wants to do, let Twitter figure out
what's good or bad for business.
Let Twitter make its decisions, assuming they're
not illegal and let the market of ideas and
the marketplace of people decide, Oh, I don't
like what Twitter is doing, so I'm not going
to be on Twitter anymore.
That's the way that they claim they operate.
But as Twitter showed us, that's not actually
the way they operate when they want to force
their disinformation onto a private platform.
Twitter Republicans at one point pushed a
law that would have prevented states from
enacting their own regulations on certain
products.
They would argue, oh, you know, we need to
protect businesses from a patchwork of different
regulations from state to state.
It's burdensome to business to say, well,
we're going to regulate your product this
way in Delaware, but in New York, it's going
to be different.
And then in Florida, it's going to be different.
So they pushed a law that said, you can't
do that.
You can't just let states regulate products
differently in each state.
But when it comes to environmental regulations,
Republicans don't care about a patchwork of
regulations.
They want to strip the EPA's federal power,
for example, to regulate greenhouse gas emissions
at the federal level.
And they listen.
There are states that aren't worried about
that.
We know if a state isn't concerned, if you
have a state like Montana, for example, Jared
Diamond has written about this a lot.
If Montana wants to let the, you know, the
soil and the land and every water be ravaged
by pollution or Wyoming, let them do it.
You can't have this oppressive EPA come in
and tell every state what they have to do.
Well, that's the principle that you are now
going against.
You're against the patchwork of laws.
But now you're okay with the patchwork of
laws.
If it might prevent the regulation of greenhouse
gases, they're willing to do it 50 different
ways and each of the 50 states, because they
want to make it difficult to regulate greenhouse
gas emissions.
Then we've got subsidies.
And this is, you know, each one of these things
I mentioning is a category unto itself with
many examples we could go into.
But let's now talk about subsidies.
The right claims to be against government
intervention in the economy, picking winners
and losers, etc.
But they have no problem handing out billions
of dollars in subsidies to certain industries,
including oil and others, when they are politically
convenient businesses.
When it comes to labor regulations, Republicans
suddenly are big fans of government intervention.
They love the idea of how can we interfere
with business to prevent workers from organizing
and forming unions, for example.
They support laws that make it more difficult
for workers to sue employers when there are
workplace violations.
You know, if you don't want to regulate the
businesses because you claim, oh, they have
a they have an incentive to regulate themselves,
and if they put out a dangerous product, they'll
get sued and they'll lose market share.
And if they don't have good working conditions
for their employees, their employees will
sue or quit.
Well, but then they also want to make it more
difficult for the employees to sue because
it's in their interests.
The truth, as many of you have long suspected,
is that Republicans only care about business
freedom and unburdening from burdensome regulations
when it serves their interests.
When it comes to protecting the environment
or protecting workers.
Suddenly, regulations are a burden that need
to be lifted.
This or you need to put in a regulation.
You need to put in a regulation that prevents
others from putting in regulations.
It's whatever is convenient at the time.
And this, at the end of the day, is bad for
the economy.
It's bad for the sort of average health of
people as they are affected by the lack of
regulation or a very oppressive type of regulation,
depending on who it is that benefits and who
is hurt, the wellbeing of workers, the environment.
I mean, you all know it.
So we're going to be going through over the
next several weeks, each of these stated principles
unburden ourselves from regulation, except
when you want to force your will onto corporations.
We're going to look at each of these.
And there are so many of these stated principles
that they claim but don't actually follow.
This is the first one.
Business freedom, low regulation.
We'll get to others over the next few weeks.